die nasa hat eine ziemliche horror
meldung herausgegeben neue kartierungen
zeigen dass deutlich mehr gletscher
grönlands von einer schmelze bedroht
sind als bisher angenommen und das hat
fatale folgen der meeresspiegel wird
stärker und schneller ansteigen als
bisher vorhergesagt wie schlimm die lage
wirklich ist und welche konsequenzen
schmelzende gletscher auch so in
deutschland haben jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
ich kann leider nichts daran ändern der
klimawandel kommt und er wird schlimm so
sieht es im moment aus die nasa hat
gemeinsam mit 30 weiteren
forschungseinrichtungen herausgefunden
dass wo zwei bis viermal so viele
gletscher grönlands von der schmelze
gefährdet sind als man bislang
angenommen hatte die neuen kartierungen
sind so genau und detailreich wie nie
zuvor und zeigen den meeresboden in
küstennähe sowie dem feld boden unter
der eisdecke die aktuelle analyse
basiert auf unfassbar vielen
datenquellen wie zb satelliten radar
luftbilder soldaten und die nasa
kampagne omg also außen melting
greenland hat daten geliefert eine menge
die kartierung zeigen dass zwei bis vier
mal so viele gletscher mehr als 200
meter unter die meeresoberfläche reichen
als man bislang angenommen hatte die
schmelze dieser teile der gletscher wird
wohl nur minimal
zum anstieg des meeresspiegels beitrage
obwohl sie über wasser kanals berg haben
aber es gibt noch einen viel schlimmeren
folgen effekt denn anders als die oberen
200 meter des meeres wasser sind die
darunter liegenden wasserschichten
vergleichsweise warm
das liegt daran dass das tiefere
meereswasser aus einer weiter südlichen
region in das gebiet strömt und somit
bis zu vier grad wärmer ist als die
oberen 200 meter des meeres wasser heißt
also im klartext gletscher die in diesen
tieferen wärmeren teil des meeres
reichen schmelzen schneller nasa
vertreter jobs will es sagt zitat diese
ergebnisse zeigen dass das eis in
grönland stärker vom klimawandel bedroht
ist als wir erwartet hatten
zitat ende die aktuelle nachricht der
nasa kommt fast zeitgleich zur
klimakonferenz in bonn wo rund 25.000
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen beraten
wie man die erderwärmung auf unter zwei
grad begrenzen kann
im vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit
das zwei grad ziel ist sehr wichtig denn
eine höhere durchschnittliche temperatur
bedeutet nach meinung der meisten
forschungsteams einen gefährlichen
klimawandels auch selbst eine geringere
globale erwärmung hat wohl dramatische
konsequenzen für das eis in grönland
berechnungen zufolge ist es schon heute
so dass die eisschmelze in grönland
stärker zum anstieg des meeresspiegels
beiträgt als die schmelze der antarktis
eine komplett
die gletscherschmelze grönlands hätte
weitreichende folgen nach den neuen
berechnungen würde der meeresspiegel
dann um sieben meter 42 ansteigen und
dabei hat jeder einzelne
gletscherabbruch ebenso wie die
kontinuierliche gletscherschmelze
direkten einfluss auf den anstieg des
meeresspiegels denn die großen gletscher
halten das inlandeis quasi fest wenn
diese umarmung also quasi wegschmilzt
ist das so als würde man einen korken
aus einer flasche ziehen
auch das inlandeis wird dann
herausfließen und der meeresspiegel wird
sehr viel höher ansteigen als prognosen
bislang annehmen es gibt schätzungen
nach denen dann bis zu einer dreiviertel
milliarde menschen weltweit betroffen
werden und du wirst alle auch wenn
grönland sehr weit von uns entfernt ist
werden vor allem wie in deutschland aber
auch die niederlande und belgien sehr
stark betroffen seien genauso wie
menschen in vielen anderen ländern
dieser welt indonesien ägypten
bangladesch oder thailand wenn der
meeresspiegel nur um einen halben bis
ganzen meter steigt würde der lebensraum
zahlreicher menschen komplett unter
wasser stehen es gibt berechnungen nach
denen bereits im jahr 2050 der prozess
des abschmelzens unwiderruflichen gang
gesetzt worden sein wird wenn sowohl das
grönländische inlandeis und auch die
antarktis eiskappe komplett schmelzen
würden würde der meeresspiegel um 70
meter ansteigen 70 meter eine unfassbare
vorstellung jedenfalls zeigen alle
modellrechnungen dass alle weltweit
meist vollkommen sehr sensibel auf die
globale klimaerwärmung reagieren an
dieser stelle können wir uns schon mal
schön selbst an die nase fassen wenn
feststeht der klimawandel wird zum
weitaus größten teil durch uns
verursacht durch die industrienationen
genau dies haben us behörden jetzt noch
mal in einem bericht bekräftigt in ihrem
thema bericht beziehen sich die autoren
und autorinnen
auch auf dem meeresspiegel sie warnen
davor dass er noch bis zum jahr 2100 um
bis zu zwei meter 40 ansteigen könnte
also wir sind gar nicht so betroffen
aber umso mehr die nächsten generationen
im klartext heißt das also das klima ist
noch lange nicht gerettet im gegenteil
und bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
berlin tun sie im moment alles dafür
damit die rettung in weite ferne
deshalb unterschreibt das generationen
manifest damit die zukunft besser wird
und nicht schlechter heartless dabei
mesalliance
hätte früher eckart von hirschhausen und
viele viele mehr hier ist der link
unbedingt mitmachen ich zähle auf euch
hier geht es weiter mit politik zerstört
die erde
da habe ich den letzten video mal etwas
dampf abgelassen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran